absolutely
[Music]
ah what a lead well me until I have a
lad for you guys here today let me start
by saying he is widely regarded as the
best ball player we've ever seen in the
game he understands rugby inside and out
has all the skills and ability to be one
of the all-time greats of the game yet
somehow after 18 years in the game which
included carving up the English
premiership for most of that time it
baffles me to Seas managed to pick up
just 16 cats for his country however
along the way he's had an Incredible
Journey on and off the field and he's
just recently released his book who am I
which is dead set the best autobiography
I've ever read he is a genuine Superstar
of the game an all-time lead of course
it is Danny Cipriani welcome mate oh
mate did you enjoy it that's awesome I
loved it mate honestly did you really
know me I I've never read a book so fast
I've got a new PB I just couldn't put it
down it was it was genuinely that good
oh man that's really cool to hear
because you're the third person outside
of my inner circle that's read it so
that's that's really like humbling to
hear something appreciate that man right
yeah how are you feeling how are you
feeling about releasing it all because
obviously
um you're pretty vulnerable in it yeah
you tell some real truth you tell it
straight so how are you feeling about
releasing it to the whole world yeah man
I feel great like living in
vulnerability is is such a power
powerful thing to do and like
um from experience uh you know I haven't
previously been vulnerable that much in
my life because you know I'm playing
rugby I'm being written about all of
these things that come into me all the
time I don't even have the opportunity
to start being vulnerable and then I met
the most beautiful woman in the world
who became my wife and I got a chance to
open up 60 of my heart and mind that
well I didn't even know was existed
because I was shut off in so many ways
but that vulnerability through lots of
different things in my life like yeah I
have shown it more and more than perhaps
traditional rugby players
um but I guess I didn't have such a
traditional route as as you read about
so it's a it's a bit um
yeah I think we take each individual as
it comes but rugby would be trying well
in this country we try we want everyone
to have one size and shape fits all but
this isn't that way no no no it's it's
such a good reading I've got so much on
sort of the top of my head that I'm Keen
to try and get through in this episode
but like all
um Model 8 episodes I like to start it
from the start to sort of get uh get to
know you from what you're like when you
first grow up so give us the rundown for
what it was like for you growing up in
London
um I grew up in a council estate so in
England counter states are like these
high-rise buildings or a place where uh
I'd say like you know 80 to 100 or plus
more people live within an environment
is the cost is working class uh but my
only experience of doing it was like fun
enjoy because I'm surrounded by lots of
other little kids you know on the
outside we don't have as much as perhaps
traditional rugby
Heritage type families and so on but
the beauty of it is I'm out in the field
I'm out in the in the cage in the back
playing sport every day football is my
first love
um just movement just being completely
engrossed in whatever I was doing my
attention my focus my presence
whenever I could just focus on something
which tended to be sport it got the best
out on me and uh and it sent me on a
wild journey of
of uh where we are here today and you
were super talented too as a kid like
what I've read is like soccer Chelsea
wanted to sign you at 10 you're unreal
at Cricket gifted rugby player so you
had all the talent
um why'd you choose rugby in the end uh
just because my two best friends played
it uh I chose like I was I went I went
to school in Wimbledon which is like
30 minute bus ride away from me 2011 and
then from 11 till 13 I had to go to
boarding school for two years and in
those two years
I started taking football a bit more
seriously and reading were coming to
watch me every week in my second season
and I had a crazy season I scored a
crazy amount of goals and then um
they were really wanting to sign me on a
white test for four years from 14 to 18
right but I was getting a bit homesick
because I'm not born in school type of
guy I wasn't I was very different to the
rest of my my crew like
um you know very outspoken and audacious
and all those things that people have
wonderfully spoke about
um
but
my two best mates went to school in
Croydon so I just wanted to go to school
with them because I wanted to be around
my best mates I was a bit sick of being
away from home and seeing them on a
Sunday just to play rugby once just
didn't seem like enough for me so I went
to that school and that was at the time
was predominantly rugby and cricket and
then that season rugby just started
building and it just kind of took off
from there 14 or 15. what did you enjoy
the most different elements I'd probably
say overall football like I play a lot
of football now
um
like just for your enjoyment because I
find it so challenging to stay so calm
but yet the movement is so explosive at
times
um batting in cricket like when I got my
eye in like I don't think there's
anything better than that like just you
versus the bowler one-on-one like sweet
shots like it's real like domination but
then obviously like I've I've loved my
whole journey in rugby map like it I
chose the best thing for me to ascend
into the best possible human I could be
learn the most lessons about myself
uh and become aligned with who I truly
am and the loving light that's in me
because that's how I feel to this day I
can't go back and rewrite anything so
I'm very grateful for the whole
experience and I guess there's one part
of your sort of upbringing that you
definitely spoke about in the book a
fair bit was your relationship with your
parents I know they divorced when you're
pretty young and sort of how hard that
relationship was for you yeah it was it
was tough man but like at that point
you you're just getting on with it like
if a kid's crying and you put an iPad in
front of them they forget about what
they're crying about if
if a kid's crying and you distract their
attention they forget but like
ultimately later on in life those things
come through and come out and that's
what the trauma sort of stays in your
body and best experience we all have
through whatever our environment is
growing up and no one has it perfect but
you know my my mum did her best in what
she could and I I and it caused
complexities in my relationship with her
but at some point you go back and
address everything and you release and
you just come from unconditional love
because for me that's the real reason
why we're here like is to connect to
love because it's the thing that
connects all of us and also my dad yeah
it was tough when he he abandoned well
he left at 10 so the feeling I had was
that abandonment but
it was tough but it also gave me the
freedom to go up
um without any constraints I didn't have
any like framework around me I didn't
um I was very free and because I had a
natural excitement towards sport I was
getting all this uh
all these great people from like Deputy
Headmasters to coaches to parents all
really like showing me love and
supporting me which
um meant I always felt I felt safe and
and looked after because I had loads of
people you know in my corner
um so to going into sport was you know
it was beautiful I don't I don't regret
any any part of it for a second but it's
a
it's been hell of a ride
and did you think you're always going to
become a professional at whatever sport
you did was that it was obviously always
the goal for you but yeah was it a
reality did you think it was a reality
For You Joe what man I just I just loved
what I'd been on the field so much yeah
I was never I was never that kid that
was planning the future I'm not an admin
type of guy I'm not like go and do this
bit like I'm fully engaged in the
present moment and
um
you know I was like that all the way
till I broke my ankle and lots of stuff
went on and then kind of came away from
it but I still found it on the field and
the whole journey says it but yeah I
wasn't that I wasn't looking too far in
the future so when
so when I was young like I always knew I
would just be playing sport but I wasn't
like I'm going to be professional I just
didn't know how it was gonna transpire I
didn't think that much
um and then I got signed up at wasps at
15 and
started getting a bit more serious so I
was like okay well this is what I'm
doing now I didn't think it was that
much of a big deal to be honest but um
yeah and when you eventually break
through with the Wasps sort of starting
side you you have a pretty incredible
first year I think you win the Heineken
Cup yeah yeah first year in the side
running the cutter mate what did you
feel like um in that season oh do you
know what it was awesome it was awesome
because I was still at school and I was
I was playing for what so I probably
paid about six or seven games that
season when I'm still at school so I
made my debut at 17 so like it was just
funny like playing for what's at the
weekend and then going in to school on
the on the Monday and like yeah just
being normal and like I I was just
normal with everyone I was friends with
everyone in my school like there was no
separation I made sure we had such a
multicultural um sick form it was so
great
um
but yeah then that year I went turn pro
Alex King was still here and he's quite
he was a senior flight half and
really understood game management
um wasn't like the most technically
gifted but really understood game
management so like made a great career
and a great warrior and and had lots of
great attributes
um
but then I done lots of work with a
Sprint coach and Sean wanted me in the
team because he knew that well from what
he saw you know I guess I did things a
little bit um unconventionally and which
which caused a lot of positive outcomes
for us so he was like look play at
fullback and I want you to mirror Alex
King all year to watch what he does but
when you get the ball just bringing up
explosivity and your excitement but
start learning and picking up the game
management side of it from him so like
he moved me to fullback
and we had a great season man like we
yeah we won the Heisman cup like my
first year out of school I don't really
remember that much of it because it was
just a blur of being involved being
completely locked into it um but
yeah it was great and then straight from
That season you're basically into the
English Camp is that right yeah so I
started training with England when I was
still at school I was 18 but then I
wasn't like playing for England then
um I was just brought into trains
and then uh
at the end of that season I was brought
in for the pre-World cup in 07 for like
three four months and it was like
what log it was man but what an amazing
experience to like
it was a it was it was a lot of fun and
then that following year Alex King left
wasps and I moved to 10 because that was
always the plan and uh yeah we won the
premiership the next year so it was just
it was like coming at me made my debut
finger and like you know all sorts was
going on yeah and that debut start for
England in particular was I guess the
one where we really uh stood up on the
international scene against Ireland put
on an absolute Clinic everyone was
calling you the savior of England rugby
and Matt yeah everything on I guess in
front of you how'd you feel after that
game
me like I was just I was happy and
excited but
it was I always just felt like it was
going to happen like I felt like that
was the route I felt like that was
um
what was was in my forecast uh I felt so
comfortable out there you know that
coach uh gave me the license to run
training all week
um and you know dictate the way I wanted
to play because I'd known Brian since I
was 15 by being in the National Academy
so he knew my uh my intellect towards
rugby and my understanding so
um
and they had been a bit like hit and
miss in the attack so I went in and I
was just like I'm 20 like what do I do
here like how do I front foot this I
didn't I didn't even have those
questions but the first thing I did is I
took meetings and I was like look this
is what we're doing this is how we're
doing it you're going here you'll go
however it was this is the Simplicity of
what we're doing and everyone probably
was so taken back and everyone just did
it and then we had a great performance
um
but yeah there's only been two games in
my career the coaches have let me run
the week and that was one all right how
did you get the confidence to be able to
stand up in front of England as such a
young kid to tell everyone what to do
like you often hear of young guys going
into environment like that and just
being right down the back you know
completely not saying anything but you
just being able to get up there dominate
a meeting dominate The Game Plan
dominate the wake and the performance
pretty incredible
when I was 14 I remember I was playing
with my my mate who's now professional
cricketer his name was Laurie Evans and
he was a good rugby player he's playing
to come off and his dad's a lovely guy
and his dad's super passionate about his
son doing well and obviously I recognize
that now but when I was 14 his dad would
just shout at him on the sidelines all
the time but I could see when he was
shouting at his son it was making
um Laurie make poor decisions and like
hesitate because he wouldn't hesitate
normally
and at that point I mean the middle of
the game we've got about 400 people
watching I've turned around I said would
you shut the [__] up and let Laurie play
like that might not be the done thing
for a 14 year old to do and you ask why
was I able to do that I think
you know as much as I felt the loss of
my father I also didn't feel that I had
to
uh impress a man or someone ahead of me
and I think that relationship when
you've got a strong Stern father at some
point you know biologically you know in
in history even in the animal kingdom
there comes a time when it's a bit
tension you have to sort of surpass I
never had that experience so when I was
in that environment I was just being me
and
um and Brian loved it so I ran with it
so you're never intimidated going into
the environments I know you're never
really intimidated by coaches and you
seem to clash heads a fair bit with them
throughout your career but you always
especially even going into England you
felt really comfortable confident who
you were yeah yeah I would but on the
Rugby field I am man yeah on the sports
field that's you know that's where I got
everything I ever wanted like as a child
even if I'm feeling certain things at
home or if I was getting
um like rejected at home or you know I
felt lost or I wasn't feeling safe at
home
being in the sports field I felt alive
so that's why I just kept going to it
and kept taking to it and
um
and yeah I I just it's just where it was
my happy place man it you know and it's
the thing that has brought me to the
most beautiful place in my in my mind
body and soul ever um to this current
date
um it's definitely been as you've read a
lot of uh ups and downs throughout it
Yeah you mentioned being on the field
was your happy place but there's a
there's a fair amount going on off it as
well so obviously there's not much
Paparazzi here in New Zealand there's a
few keyboard Warriors but there's no
real media like you guys get over there
you I've never seen a player sort of
drag through the paparazzi media like
you have through your career I guess
that started sort of after that England
game
um a few celebrity relationships too
yeah it was a bit before it was a bit
before the week before I went to give
tickets on a Wednesday to a friend who
was in a nightclub I was on the way back
from my Physio and I got a snapped
coming out and then I got dropped from
playing fullback against Scotland the
week before that Island game yeah and
then it just like even though I'd been
written about a lot considering rugby
players before that that kind of just
took it off and then as you mentioned I
had certain girlfriends in the public
eye and that just let them let them run
with it really and how'd you find it or
how do you find being thrown through
that media like that
man if you ask me at different points in
my life you would have had very
different answers like
the the beauty of being able to reflect
at this point and being being present
and Center is you know I look back with
everything with a loving light and a
Learning lesson or an experience or
wisdom that I've learned from
um when you're in the ringer of it and
the emotional turmoil and you don't know
who you are and you're figuring that out
and
you're being judged and critiqued for
Snippets of your life and
that doesn't align with who your soul is
or what you want to do in life but
you're you're behaving impulsively
because there's lots of things like I
said from childhood that are coming
through me in some of my behaviors like
um which are all my responsibility but
you know I was completely unemotionally
and I'm emotionally unavailable to women
but yet that the the toy and the play
with it
um the the flirtation and the
they're just warm to me they warm to me
it wasn't like it wasn't it wasn't a
an effort it wasn't like manipulating it
just they just wanted me but yeah I was
so emotionally unavailable which
probably tells you a lot you know like
when a man's emotion available
mysterious like women tend to flock to
that and
I'm reflecting them in hindsight but
when I'm in it I'm just behaving as such
like
because you know if uh
you know if you've got a young daughter
you don't want her to be with someone
who's emotionally unavailable because
it's just going to be a rocky road you
know yeah you know it was a it was uh
it was interesting because
it took me out of myself a lot it sent
me into
you know really not really being
confused I had a lot of my validation
externally because even as a young kid
as I explained I went and played sport
I was happy on the field I was getting
all this praise and everyone saw me for
who I was who I felt I was
in my soul so then I felt great about it
but then at this point now I'm also
getting external validation but now it's
negative so I'm feeling it in the same
manner not that air my ego ran with it
but
I'm getting all this negativity and I'm
wearing it and it took me into a place
of just like really soul-seeking and
searching and what's so beautiful is the
Life Is Life The Universe what put the
most amazing people in front of me at
different points in my life so I could
learn some amazing bits of their wisdom
and love and life because you know I
didn't have the I wouldn't call my mum
and dad if something was going wrong I
didn't have that but the universe
brought amazing people into my world I
was able to lean on
and
you know provide me some insight on
knowledge within certain times or even
just sit with me and see me for who I
really was and those people were
invaluable to me because it it really
kept me going
um in loads of different ways and you
speak about
um sort of the woman and your
relationship with women and sort of one
part that definitely blew me away around
your book was your squad of woman like
20 to 30 women going
um you know sometimes three a day
threesomes were normal it was like
incredible a lot of men would just look
at that and say like you are living the
absolute dream yeah but what's it like
being actually in there it's so it's so
far from the truth like Yeah The Moments
are fun like
the the moment of the physical contact
of what sex is and the the play that's
fun
but again throughout a day you know that
might last an hour or so you know I got
a bit of stamina
the rest of your day you're feeling
completely
um
like it's a it's a it's a higher trying
to continuously get all the time
um but yeah it's stemming from a place
not of like Purity and love and and joy
it actually stem in from a place of like
a need of that validation or that
feeling or being seen or that love that
you think is love that I've got no idea
about I'm diving into the whole time
without anyone going well no this is not
what you know not that
not that anyone well no one did was like
coming to speak to me about it because I
guess I'm not sharing that with people
because everyone like you say in the
rugby worlds thinking oh well he's the
man like well it's not like any person
that behaves like that is a lost soul
man and anyone that behaves in that
manner with so many different broads
and it it like that and my only
um correlation to it is I've met the
love of my life and I've and I've met
someone who I've opened up to fully
Watson or stolen or everything top to
bottom and the feeling I have every day
in love in light with her it doesn't
even compare to how I was behaving
previously so all of those ways of
Behaving from The Outsiders all you go
man-made thinking it's great like it's
nothing Man compared to what committing
your life is to one woman and going on
that journey and someone you truly love
and turning up for every day and
that sensation is so much greater
there's no up and down there is just a
state of joy for me um
uh and that's what I commit to in my
work uh with what I study and what I
look at and and but also just how I live
my life that's so good and I don't
remember your story about like your
first girlfriend I wonder if that had a
an effect on you and the rest of your
girlfriends I think you're 18 she was
30. you tell her you don't want to be
with her anymore and it's all pretty
dramatic yeah yeah that it could you
know what it could have in hindsight
um because that experience there was
like
far out man I've said what I want to say
here and she now wants to hurt herself
so
it kind of stopped
doing that and I let people down way
more gently but in doing so it probably
kept people a bit more attached to me in
a way so they probably felt a bit like
um that's probably why people sell
stories on me because they probably
thought the emotional connection of some
form or or matter but
um
yeah it was a it was definitely um it
was definitely when I look back maybe
that was something to do with it but who
knows so did she just jump out of the
car is that what happened she went to
open the open the door and I stopped her
and I
um yeah I pulled over and I was like
what what are you doing
um yeah but you know
it I don't I don't judge that because
for whatever reason whatever happened in
her life that was the way she felt to
behave and react uh
it just I guess threw me off a bit in in
terms of saying trip like
saying look now I don't want to be with
you here because
that's what happened like I didn't want
to do that again and it must have been a
fair bit of admin for you like you you
talk about
um trying to not hurt anyone's feelings
and you know sort of keep the whole
Squad happy like Fair bit of admin for
you off the field it was it wasn't
it wasn't I say it's so frivency in the
where I say Squad but like I say that as
a joke yeah yeah I get there my
teammates oh and that I would just say
it's a joke because I didn't want to
speak about names or details so I just
kept it as that um
but yeah you know I had a lot of people
that I guess I
slept with for a long time over the
years and
you know I met a lot of great people
doing it too but you know there's
nothing that can compare to meeting
um the love of your life yeah all right
here
it is like a drop in the ocean of of
what it truly is and
you know I share these experiences which
you know are vulnerable and open and
over here you should see the media now
man they're going nuts like
they're taking Snippets of the book as
you can imagine and just posting that as
the story which is now like everyone's
like [__] he's an [__] like well
you know read the book it's different
but at the end of the day
that's just how the media play that's
what they do I've understood the way
they narrate and create stories
um
but yeah the whole the whole journey man
like
man it's been fun yeah and let's get
back on to on the field like you spoke
about it before but yeah you had a
pretty bad break and dislocation of your
ankle
um just when you were flying bad timing
how was how was that for you to deal
with especially mentally
yeah do you know what it my ankle was
flipped round my bone was coming out my
foot I hate those it felt like really
bad cramp and then I looked in my foot
and it felt like really bad cramping man
yeah that's bad crap I looked at my foot
and then
my brain goes nah this is how you're
meant to feel when the pain goes wrong
and I was just like
like that I was worried because they
originally thought that I might not pay
again there was all Whispers but then my
physio who's an absolute angel of a
human is one of the best out there he's
the best out there he um
he was in the surgery with the surgeon
because he can help with surgery and so
on and as soon as I woke up he was like
the healing was great the alignment was
great you're going to be fine as soon as
hit that
even that day I didn't really feel pain
apart from when he treated it when he
treated it it was so it was the worst
pain ever it was worse than breaking it
breaking down the scar tissue and
getting that all out like all of that
stuff but
you know for me I've always used
injuries as a chance to like just better
myself in some form some way because
someone said to me like when you get
injured for a couple months or a long
period when you're young it does seem
like the end of the world but it puts
years on at the end of your career like
playing rugby and training is taxing
especially over here I don't know what
your training routines like but here
they just flogged the boys there's no
real thought behind it it's just
you see the boys at the weekend play for
England now and everyone's like they're
unfit I'm like no they're tired yeah
they're tired I know what it's like they
over exert and train when ultimately you
want you want to hold a bit back so when
they come out on Saturday you're out
like you're out just out the traps do
you know what I mean but rugby doesn't
understand that concept it's all about
hit the nail into the ground as often as
possible over here but
you know it doesn't always win the race
um
but yeah so injuries for me were a
chance to recalibrate we can figure like
better some other part of my body you
know just just settle down how are
England going to change that such an
interesting point around
um they're tired and just the the
mindset going into the weeks and how
they're going to change that
I think they have to employ people who
who do it very differently I think not
employing Scott Robertson
like whether it was now or later you
know that's something they probably need
to look to do because
uh
he has a from what from speaking to him
and from what you said he's got a
completely different Outlook to to rugby
and and you see that you see people in
the way people move man like people in
New Zealand aren't necessarily better
athletes and people here but yet they
look fresher and more able to be more
fluid and looser but that's not it's
through their physical capabilities
that's also through a relaxation of the
mind of being present of being and
allowed to go and express yourself
because being allowed to express
yourself and playing through Joy means
you're naturally more fluid in movement
you see it within football you see it
within
um Steph Curry you see it within top
athletes yeah there's a there's a
there's a flow there's a movement to it
whereas here our culture and our sport
is very much like must do it prove it
over and over again like
go order if you don't go harder go even
harder tomorrow like keep working keep
working because like that's the answer
but if that was the answer then life
would be so easy if it was just to keep
working but do you think we're put on
this Earth to just keep working we're
here to find Joy find love so if you
play in that expression you're only ever
going to see more fluid more lucid and
better movement like it's the highest
energy to to play to but
um
you know our culture here you know
it's just kind of not rap steeped in
that really
um
especially in rugby uh and I guess it's
kind of proven over the years them not
picking people like Christian Wade or
Sam Simmons or people that would have
played for the All Blacks like Christian
Wade is the best Winger I've ever seen
with the ball in hand it's like there's
no one that can do what he can do and
and I and I'm not saying it from a
biased perspective I'm looking at like
there's obviously some other phenomenal
Wingers that you guys have got like but
in terms of getting out of a phone box
I'm doing it without anything on the
shirt
yeah you're right it's interesting hey
it's such a fascinating
um situation with and comparison between
the the two Nations but
um is that why you sort of went over to
um Melbourne and gave Super Rugby a go
no I so I went there because Martin
Johnson said I wasn't in his plans for
England so I was like I'm not gonna I'm
not going to bang my head against the
wall for the next three years before the
World Cup because I only played rugby to
play for England really when it started
happening because I wanted to be the
best like I wanted everyone to see me as
the best okay so
um
and that and that also stems from a lack
of two that's like the there's there's
something for me to want to be seen and
go on that journey and go through all
this turmoil and they ups and downs to
feel like I'm the best is also some from
some place of
not feeling good enough too because if
you feel good enough and you just play
from Joy and Fun and Freedom then you
don't have that necessary drive it might
just happen like you put the effort and
the work in which obviously comes with
it
um
but yeah I went to Melbourne because
I've always Super Rugby was the first
competition I ever watched on TV and the
Wellington hurricanes were the first
team I ever watched and I used to watch
Christian Collins
[Music]
um
lomu
Rodney serialu Jerry Collins you know
who's the Who is the tall Ginger lot
Paul tato right yeah yeah it's true
Hurricane fan oh Tito
um
yeah that was my team man that when I
was when I was a kid so I didn't know
anything about English rugby I just wake
up on Saturdays and watch Christian
Cullen just cut everyone in a new way he
was gifted a man he could just slice
yeah D like no one else me
yeah and I remember reading one quote
that really stood out to me was like
Melbourne seemed like a better option
than putting a gun to your head like
yeah that was that's how deep it was for
you wasn't it because there was a moment
um leading up to that where it did get
pretty dark and heavy for you yeah it
did it was dark and heavy because you
know I would I'd walk down the street
and
you know
I would see people look at me and people
wouldn't be subtle so like if they see
someone they know they're like Double
Take again and it's not like a bad fault
of theirs but if you see someone you
kind of recognize you might think you
know him I get it like and I'd always
get that and then you'd hear people who
sipriani and like I'm literally one
meter away I can hear people saying it
so like I just felt that with a lot of
places I went to
um
and I would always my first my brain
would go straight to negativity it would
go straight to
um they're saying to that negative about
me because that's all I read that's all
I saw that's all people were saying so I
was basing how I felt or myself on the
outside world but it didn't align with
who I was so I felt so conflicted yes I
was just in a place where I felt so
claustrophobic I couldn't go anywhere
like I wouldn't be able to phone you
know my nearest family members and tell
her how my feeling because the the
response I would get would be quite an
aggressive one back so I just you know
not for my dad as much but that was just
the way it was
so I felt very alone like I grew up
alone I also felt alone in my dark times
too you know um
but
you know
yeah divine intervention lots of things
happen didn't go that way and I did go
to Melbourne and
you know I probably didn't when I was in
Melbourne give my uh best efforts
because when I went there I went there
with all the intention to do so thinking
Rodney McQueen's World Cup winning coach
you know Rugby's going to be great over
there all these fantasies about Super
Rugby and then um I went over there and
I realized their English with an Aussie
accent like this is not this is not
expansive free-flowing rugby so straight
away I was just kind of like [__] it I'm
in Australia
I didn't really drink alcohol to that
point true I'm gonna start hanging out
with my teammates and have some fun like
you know it was a it was a well-paid gap
year it felt like yeah I I laughed when
you said around the move Apple which was
the um 15-man pick and go like if you've
come to play some expensive um Super
Rugby and your coaches coming up with a
15-man pick and go that is the score on
you I don't get what I love about rugby
and the same would happen in England if
a coach said that in England people
would just do it right yeah
but what I love about rugby is I'm there
going you can't be for real with this
and everyone's saying it but no one says
anything yeah so I'm right and you know
like I said at 20 I went and led the
team
at 22 I'm still not going to be afraid
to say if I
I'm not going to do it in the derogatory
manner but when he's like Danny why not
get involved in the pick and go I said
I'm not I'm I'm not taking part in that
mate because
it's not
there's no evidence or anything that
this is going to be efficiently like
it's not gonna work yeah and you've got
people like Sterling mortal lock going
come on Danny mate just come on just
give it a go I'm like I'm like Sterling
you know this is [__] so why are we
doing it
and we're like but yeah I'm trouble no
I'm just standing up for what I believe
in like I'm not come on give me some
understanding of
why you think it's going to work and
then the first play against the tars
turn the ball over Curly Bill goes the
length
I wasn't even I didn't get to start the
first game because I wouldn't do Apple
it was mad yeah it's so true the way
like when players um don't believe in
something they just complain and the
sheds but
um you're obviously different you're
willing to go straight to the coaches as
you should and have a genuine discussion
around the best option yeah yeah well do
you know what I I was still learning the
game at that point like the ins and outs
the nooks and crannies of it like my
ability on the ball was was I could do
whatever I wanted but I now need to
configure how do I get everyone around
me understand that too so I had those
couple years at Melbourne learning a lot
I learned a lot from Andrew John's uh
ball playing wise
um I had a great little group with like
curtly and James you know we did lots of
extra training Richard King e and Cooper
vuna
um we had a great little group Peter
Peter Matthews
yeah it was great
um and then I went for sale for my first
year when I got back from England and I
let the coach run the team again and we
almost got relegated
and uh I after that season I was like
I'm not I'm not letting my career be in
the mercy of another man's Vision like
unless what they say aligns and I feel
what he's saying because when it comes
to effective ball play it's not
Whimsical there's a flow to it there's a
way to do it it's a way to commit
Defenders there's a way to understand
what's happening rugby is the same as
basketball and football in terms of it's
it's attacking space it's how you pull
Defenders out
basketball's very much all in front of
you there's a 360 element to it when you
get to the D
football is a 360 game Rugby's 180 much
more linear so it's just about moving
the pieces and for me if if the the
formation the framework doesn't align up
to that create a numerical advantages
then
you just you're just it's just paying 50
50 all the time running into people
and
I'm not saying there's not a place for
it like people think oh you just want to
throw the ball about it's not the case
you look at someone like South Africa
and they're deep rooted in culture and
tradition you see how connected they are
as a group like I went and saw Willy
LaRue the other day before they played
New Zealand all right two days before
the calmness
the the way that everyone hugs everyone
greets everyone there's a real
connection there that's so powerful
that's more powerful than a game of
rugby and and you feel that on the field
when they take it on there when you take
it out there like there's no bravado
there's no Macho they are that they are
live it it's different whereas in
England we have this we've got to look
like you're wearing the right jumper and
you've seen the right thing and you're
talking in the right voice like how do
you connect to that like for me you know
and
yeah that's I don't even know what the
point was but that's what we're doing
you've nailed it but did you you speak
about the sort of cultures and stuff you
would have fit in quite well with a few
of those Lads in the Melbourne Rebels
securely Bells James O'Connell
especially at that time of yours yeah we
would we was a bit loose then
and you mentioned you didn't drink uh
pretty much going until you got over
there yeah not really you found
prescription drugs as well the Tramadols
oh mate like it was so apparent
everywhere and I was like
but yeah it was uh
you know you know Aussies are like
English people like they love to drink
and
you imagine if if england was sunny nine
months of the year I don't I don't think
we'd get anything done as a nation like
nothing
hint royalties don't get anything done
like they're nine months a year of
getting pissed like
they're the same as us and them like
that's the culture of what it is and
you know I don't I don't drink I don't
drink now so rarely as a celebration I
don't like it's depressing it pulls me
down it's not anything that I enjoy but
um it really is embedded in our culture
here and and I find it mad because if
you go back to 1970 whenever they made
alcohol legal right
and they then if they if they brought it
to this current day and go this is what
it is this poison here is going to make
you behave potentially like a b or c
um is it going to be FDA approved
everyone be like mate that sounds like a
horror drug yeah but yeah it's accepted
now because it's just been around for so
many years like
I'm not uh not massive it it does a lot
more work than good and what about um
prescription drugs as well because I see
that in the game still like it's still a
messy part of it people chopping back
the Tramadols just to sort of get
through
what's your thoughts on it do you know
what I think it used to be really easy
accessible over here yeah um and when I
was in Oz
um they're strictly with it now because
Tramadol itself has become an enlisted
drug so there needs to be more
approachable behind getting it but
I used to enjoy this feeling of like
just being numbed because I was wanting
to not be in my mind like when I was
taking it I felt like I could be a
little bit Freer and enjoy my days a bit
more but you know that's such a dark a
bad road to go down
um
but I never at one point felt like I was
addicted to it I never wanted to leave
myself addicted to anything because then
that's another hurdle you've got to
overcome you've just got to figure out
why where it's coming from like what are
you trying to hide what are you trying
to replace what you're trying to numb or
get rid of um but yeah I get it at times
it's fun too but you know in terms of
the long-term
um being on this planet and and feeling
the full effects of life and and what's
available to you you don't want to numb
yourself down to it you need to feel it
you need to feel every emotion you need
to not be afraid to letting it out
letting it go
um
especially as men because you know we we
you're grown up you're brought up in a
different manner but being able to
express emotion at any point you know it
gives you a full flavor of life doesn't
mean you're going to be an emotional guy
but
if you are able to express it from a
young age then you're going to be able
to handle very emotionally difficult
scenarios in a much clearer calmer
manner than people will spotted it up
and react in anger or reacting out
frustration so
um yeah for me you know it was a a means
to an end but yeah it was something I
part took in what's the key to that
what's the key to especially with
younger guys uh I guess helping them be
able to express themselves
I think I think the most difficult thing
when you love someone might be a child
or you know
anyone you love is seeing them in pain
like
because you want to take it away from
them so you want to be like it's going
to be okay don't worry you're going to
be all right come on just keep going
yeah right but just being there is
sometimes enough like because you're
actually stopping that sensation for
that kid or or playing out that whole
process of what's Happening of crying of
I mean it's our Natural Instinct like
and it sounds so
you don't just sit back and go or cry
out if I go like you're not I'm not
saying to do that do you know what I
mean be present be there try and get
down on the level find out how things
are going and
but don't try and stop their experience
of what they're feeling
at a young age
because even though they might be
emotional children they're going to be
much more emotionally stable adults but
I know a lot of parents who see kids
that cry when you're out in public or
they're out with things you want to
crush your child up because you want
people to think you've got a cry kid but
you don't [__] matter like
anyone who thinks that about them is
completely forgets being a baby
themselves it's ridiculous yeah no that
is that is good advice and good good
reminder for all the parents out there
but you eventually move back to the UK
you move back to sale like you spoke
about and that was purely to
um Chase your England dream again yeah
man it was awesome I went back to say I
want to play for England
um went to a very like hard-nosed
Northern Club
uh the first year was absolutely hideous
because
I was like just letting the coach run
the team
um and I've still figuring things out
but then I was just next year I met my
mentor end of that season and things
changed and I just found my found a way
to play the game but not just
um exciting for myself I thought my
whole rest of my career was spent uh
giving New Perspectives to other players
and and giving them an understanding
of just giving them a bit more time on
the ball like I I never did anything for
them they did it all but I just gave
them a few pointers of positioning or
foot speed or certain little bits so
when they did want to ball play they
were fully in control of what they were
doing
um and I used to love doing that because
it was it was such a small amount of
things that I had experienced myself but
then sharing that Insight you can then
see they get in the board and they've
got all this time to make great
decisions they're not rushed with the
past you know they understand they're
committing Defenders and then it was
just like I just really enjoyed the
aspect of um of my career and I spent uh
the majority of my time doing that and
then you moved to the worst I think you
spoke about it around it basically to
give yourself the ability to play the
style you wanted to at sale so going to
worst was basically around that was it I
was I wasn't I just missed out on the
World Cup prediction
um and everyone that was getting picked
was in a top four team so I thought okay
I've got to go to one of those teams
like and was for like third or fourth of
the year before
um I was going to go to Quinn's but I
met Diane he told me that he wanted me
to come run his attack yeah and I said
to him in the meeting I went you want me
to run the whole attack do you know what
that means and he's like no I want you
to do that okay so then um
get to wasps and after like
after like x amount of weeks of
pre-season I'm not playing in the first
preseason game
yeah and I I was like why I don't get
you want me to come and do this and he
just didn't like the fact I guess that I
was taking eyes off him like there's
such a control element here
um but I'm on the field with the boys
and I want to upskill everyone or give
someone not upskilled but I want
everyone to be the most efficient they
can be in every position that as
possible within a framework which suits
everyone
um
but yeah we had this preseason game we
were playing the team that just got
promoted and
we were losing was 20 minutes ago and he
put me off the bench and we ended up
winning the game and then he started me
in every game ever since because
the need to win for him was more
important than his ego so that's kind of
what happened and you mentioned a little
bit around missing out on England and I
guess that was pretty much the story of
your career like playing really good
footie but never getting an opportunity
really to
um make yourself a true International
player on the big stage so yeah talk
about missing out on that World Cup
um how hard was that one for you yeah
man you know what it
I wouldn't say I sat with it for long
thinking it was hard because I I was in
a place where I was
I was working through a lot and I was
accepting whatever comes my way like
guess how I handle being present and
yeah
[Music]
um
I still had lots of frustration around
it but
you know
going into the uh World Cup I had a
storm in rehearsal like the in 17
minutes and then
they didn't pick me so I was like okay
that's that's how it is and I look back
at you know Martin Johnson's Reign it
wasn't deemed successful when
Lancaster's Reign wasn't deemed
successful and Eddie Jones's Reign
wasn't deemed successful
um and they all didn't pick me
uh well they did sporadically but
you know my inclusion with England from
2014 onwards I didn't have a bad game or
a bad moment uh
you know I remember in 2018 Eddie Jones
The Legend
um he picked me
they'd lost seven games in a row yeah
and he picked me to play against Africa
it was pissing it down like the worst
torrential rain ever and uh like just
not my day but
um
stayed within it 70 minutes in you know
chasing box kicks making my tackles
doing what I had to do
but then as soon as I had a moment to do
something I did it just impulsively
instinctively
um and we scored and we won the game
and like I thought it was losing the
streak and then now I don't make the
squad again for for like a whole year
I'm like Oh my days this guy is just you
know you just don't like me yeah why do
you think that is why do you think those
sort of three coaches or any England
coach hasn't got along with you or
hasn't liked you it's tough it's tough
it's tough today because like
I'm then speaking for them but I can
only speak on the people they pick and
the leadership groups they create
and there's a lot of Great Men in there
I'm not remotely ever
the thing is when I speak is not
anyone's person it's not anyone's Soul
yeah it's just from the behaviors that
they display and I don't take that as
them because we all want to be better we
all want to try our best we want to come
from love but a lot of people's life
experience don't allow you to do it and
you know I've been judged to high hill
so why am I going to go back into bit of
that judgment into the world so I only
speak about what I see in a in a
leadership format and Martin Johnson
Stuart Lancaster and Eddie all selected
people who would do as they say who
would execute what they want and I think
around me there's a certain element of
uncertainty as a coach because you know
I don't know what I'm going to do I'm in
the moment like
I don't want to know it because then I
don't because you don't know until
you're in the moment like
so
that uncertainty for them made them feel
like maybe out of control or
like I was at risk but
I I explained in the book like playing
for England was easier than playing Club
rugby
for everyone because you're playing with
the best players yeah with all the same
mindset with the most perfect nutrition
with the most perfect environment but in
England where they get it
catastrophically wrong
is they hype everything up they make it
the biggest occasion the biggest thing
representing your country you can say
that all out there in the media and you
can pipe up a fight like they do in the
UFC
but come game day you want to be joyous
and calm and able to do anything you
want you don't want to coach in that
fashion but they don't understand that
we we see the Fanfare the the excitement
of Fighters when it comes to UFC and
what they speak about or boxing before
huge game fights and it feels like they
want to kill each other
it's just a way to sell a fire yeah in
that training it's all about staying
fluid relax relax your shoulders pop it
out like you can't
you can't go into a fight wanted to kill
someone you're gonna get knocked out by
these absolute artists of what they do
but we just have that disconnect in such
a huge way that we think hard work is
going to solve it all and it's not
really the case when you say you like
going to the line or you don't like to
preempt anything obviously one of the
best decision makers at the line in the
game
are you going at that line with no
preconceived ideas you're just always
taking it to the line with all options
available
you're you're reading Lots at different
points there's different points on the
field from a 15 meter line if there's a
rock and you're you're going long side
and there's a rock you know they're
going to fold three maybe two in the
defense two in The Ruck five two in the
backfield seven they could have eight
maybe seven with a sweeper right so you
roughly know numerically where people
are going to be you can check people
folding people moving and things around
like you're scanning you have that
awareness of what's going on and around
you the whole time but then you also
recognize at times they might overstack
alongside so if I'm if I've got the ball
and I'm in the middle of the field and
I'm playing to the left and I know the
defense is heavily stacked rather than
make like the best decision I can in
terms of
uh I'll make the most efficient one
which will be if I play short here
attract Defenders they'll still fold the
same amount because
In the Heat of the battle teams get
their folds mixed up I know we're going
to go this way we'll get you so you kind
of always aware of what's going on
around you but then obviously when you
get the ball and you go at the line and
you commit and you go deep into the line
into that space of uncertainty when
you're at the line ready to play I'm
just focused on um Defenders uh hips and
shoulders and and their body shapes
um but I also know when I move with a
certain speed what it's going to do I
don't really look at the guy in front of
me it's like the guy next to me and the
one after that and I know if I move at a
certain speed that they're going to be
rooted and attracted in certain ways
especially if I've got my team locked
and loaded in the right positions on the
inside shoulders taking people on
um you can have certain players like
your brother Tommy Marshall where you
know he would just he would just read my
body shape so I knew with him if I'm
going square but I kick out on one he's
just going to follow me and do it but
not yeah not every player has that
intuition at that moment to do it so
yeah you also have to play to the
players around you that doesn't mean
anyone's Better or Worse everyone's got
different strengths those more physical
guys they want to be more on top of
people but you know there's lots of
players I've played with that had
finesse that were big too
um yeah so yeah when it comes to going
to the line and doing that you you
commit and you train and you you learn
what it feels like to go deep into it
and play as late as possible but that
doesn't mean every time
doing the right thing means each
situation is slightly different and you
play to it accordingly that's that's how
it how I do it I love it true insight
into the absolute wizard at playing the
ball at the line no I don't know about
that well one thing I did love about
your sort of story was your resilience
to
I guess keep striving for their England
Jersey obviously had big offers from
France regularly um Japan but you just
kept um pursuing this England dream it
no matter how unlikely it was with the
certain coaches you just keep trying to
break them down yeah you know what I I
was in like you know the whole time my
character was getting assassinated like
in 2015 coaches would be like you're not
in the squad every single day you don't
know what people's characters are like
they would always lean into that element
of things with me because it was easy
because that narrative was already built
so they could say that about me
um but that was just a way to protect
them from not picking me at times
um
but I was wearing all of that like you
you're doing this so you can pick who
you want to pick but
I've got to go home and deal with the
fact that everyone now listens to what
you say because you're the coach
and people are now as human I'm this bad
character
um
and
you know having to always keep going in
those moments is like where I learned to
really know myself but I also have
which I you know when I look back in my
life the times I would get up and keep
going and keep playing and keep turning
up like there's something deep within
every single person like an energy of
power there's there's something with you
connect to the faith of it that does
keep you going that keeps us protected
because
it the reason why we're here is
unexplainable it's all magical in that
sense like we can't know for certain you
can't know for fact otherwise if you
must know the facts and the truth of it
you're gonna miss out on all the mystery
of what is
um what could be so for me that thing
would always drive me and I would I
would always keep going because I was
determined to like learn my psyche
myself in every single way
um
and just not bow down to these people
that
with an X Y and Z to me because it
didn't align with me it didn't feel
right it didn't feel right the way that
the game was coached the way the game is
is ran it didn't feel right to me the
way that
um all of that stuff in this country but
it's now coming to fruition that way
like we've just lost three Premiership
teams English rugby is at its lowest ebb
everything is crumbling because of this
facade of we've got to keep doing the
right thing and must look like we're
doing the right thing like it
it's actually fear that's you leading in
fear like
committing to the truth and love means
that you commit to doing the right thing
in the moment and sometimes it could be
messy sometimes it could be whatever it
is so for me it was just always
connecting to like myself as much as I
could and I met some great people who
you know I learned meditation from like
over about 10 years ago and
man I've been on such a interesting
Journey which has
um brought me to this day
um and still even now like I've got the
whole nation judging me based on
extracts from my books like you know
some of the stuff people are saying is
so ludicrous but
yeah you know it
it's from their perspective from what
they see and some of it's also Fair like
yeah you can make that judgment but
you're now making a judgment on
something 13 years ago like yeah that's
not the story that's if we judge people
on moments in time in the past when do
we ever move forward
if we judge moments if we judge moments
of time in the past then we stay rooted
in racial discrimination we stay rooted
in religious segregation
we can only allow people to keep moving
forward and keep
proving and allowing people to grow and
express and come from love right and
that is every single message I ever want
to deliver that's everything that I want
to stand up for in every single way
shape or form because I know so many
athletes get so much critique on social
and it can affect their mental health
and and so on and I've been in that
position where I've felt the weight of
it
but until you learn your internal and
know yourself
from a loving place because if you've
got malicious behaviors or
you know if you you know doing things as
itself toward or self-gain or negative
in that way you can't live in a clear
spirit and a clear light so
for me it's just about cleaning up
yourself where you're coming from
because everyone wants to be loving like
you know our life takes us away from
that through different experiences
but always connecting to that and
rooting to that is how I live my days
and that is what keeps me in the faith
and and the joy of spreading the message
from my books I'm able to
um hopefully
um just share that with with England
because you guys probably get a lot more
of it in New Zealand but over here we
don't um you know and I've been in the
middle of the media storm and they're
posting things now which are causing
people like I said to to react in
certain ways but I just want to shine a
light on it all really to
um spread the word of Love bro I love it
so so powerful and sort of why actually
at the start like how you're feeling
about releasing it because obviously
throughout your career
um anything anytime you made an error or
you stuffed up it was fully
um they Twisted it to make you out to
the villain and I can only imagine what
they're gonna you've seen it from these
Snippets already you're saying that
they're gonna just take any little bit
out of this book and try and I guess
stick to that narrative yeah they are I
I understand that the um the reaction
but
for athletes you know I would love every
athlete to understand this right if you
squeeze orange juice if you squeeze an
orange orange juice comes out if you
squeeze a human and they tweet hate
that's what comes out of them
you wouldn't eat a bad orange would you
you wouldn't take on the nutrients of a
bad orange you just throw it away so
anyone that spits that type of
anger
don't even take it on and I know it's
easier to said than done
um
but that's how I now view it because I
would never openly say negativity in
that way to someone else but in England
the original trolls the original
keyboard Warriors are our tabloids and
newspapers and they have a license to do
and say what they want right and it
affected me at my point really to a core
and they kept me accountable along the
way but through my book I want to keep
them accountable because I lost someone
who is a beautiful light in this world I
didn't lose them the world lost them
their mum lost them their sister their
friends the cause
of the hate that they spit continuously
she didn't feel lucky to keep going on
and she ended up taking her own life so
that is one of the biggest driving
forces that I will continue on this line
of love and like because ultimately
um
I made it out I was able to and she
hasn't so I know she'd be proud of me
for taking the steps that I am and you
know I'm gonna Stick it to the Man and
that's the best thing I can say I'm
gonna just reveal to themselves what's
what because
you know that's
it's just not acceptable
it's not acceptable in this modern day
and you speak about that moment
obviously
would have been the most toughest moment
of your life was when you found out that
news that Carolina had taken her life
how how old is that for you to
deal with
man like you don't ever go over it no
like it's within it's within like I was
sat on a Friday night
about to play a game and she tried to
call me yeah and I couldn't answer and I
texted and I can't speak I'm in the
changing room
I didn't know the levels where she was
at she didn't explain to me she was that
far down the line she was always asking
inquisitive questions
and then I play a game of rugby
and then I find out the next day she's
dead
and I'm thinking for a game of rugby I
couldn't answer the phone like I know
like it's not my fault I know those
things but naturally I have those
feelings come up because I know I could
have made an impact and changed the
course of it I felt so
but it was one of the biggest things for
me to to then release some of the [__]
off my chest that I was holding on to
because the thing she was fear for laws
or shameful of or worried about
everyone goes through [__] man
but because the way that the media speak
about you and put you on this thing and
take you down and
and then the consistency of everyone
telling you all these same messages
man it's tough at times not for it to
get to your your Mentor or your heart or
any way shape or form
and I I just you know
I end up on the Monday
for 45 minutes talking in front of the
boys I burst I was crying the whole time
I was a mess
I was releasing so much [__] that
I'd hold on to [__] I hadn't really told
people and like I then did a video and
did the same thing because it was the
only way I could get off this my chest
this pain I was feeling how did the boys
react to that
you know what like it's tough because
some of the younger boys were like oh
come and give me hugs and some of them
all boys I was a bit close to who did
but I also understand that seeing a man
be so raw and emotion can also be quite
uncomfortable for some people man so
like especially in England like you know
we don't we're not
a nation full of emotional intelligence
in that way
um and and not not through anyone's
fault but just the culture and the and
the depression after the war that you
know we're here in this self-deprecating
Society here which
um
it doesn't really want you to reveal
anything too much because you're going
to get knocked down and that's you know
predetermined a lot by the media and how
they behave and what they do to everyone
they knock down everyone they possibly
can so it gives a dark cloud over the
whole country
um
but yeah just stuff broken me man and
you know
I went on a whirlwind man because
like six weeks later I found out my my
wife to be is pregnant
like but I was stuck in Malibu during
covid
um
trying to just Center myself and like
train with the people I've been trained
to for years
so then I've got all these things going
on man like I'm dealing with a lot and
now I know I'm going to be a dad and
like all these things are happening and
you know it
it
sent me on a path now to do the book
I've done and to speak the way I want to
speak and I'm you know I've got a whole
media tour coming up and I'm going to be
speaking in front of daytime TV shows
I'm not going to censor one [__]
thing I say man I might not curse if
it's the morning but
because I don't need to swear to make my
point yeah I did then because I felt it
was more powerful yeah um
but through my experience of everything
that's happened
and the way that we're going in this
country by
it's the only thing I know to do is to
say what I feel and from my heart I've
always been like that right yeah it's
just so cool so cool to to hear it hear
it um obviously read in the book but
hear it from your face to face and
everyone gets opportunity to listen but
you speak about the the low of the death
and the high of your new relationship
the high of
um a baby on the way
and then that's all taken away from you
like
it doesn't get any harder
yeah you know what right
if it wasn't for him I wouldn't
I wouldn't have met the love of my life
because as soon as I found out she was
pregnant
I said you know
no matter what we need to tell each
other 100 of the truth because we need
to be the best parents for this kid yeah
okay and
I'm not censoring anything because it's
not about me anymore there's another
life up late
I can't hold on to this thing that I'm
holding on to for so long
all by myself because there's another
life at play so
um
man I man we had a messy couple messy 12
months man I broke down so much told her
so much that I've been holding on to and
you know
she held space and it was uh
and we're here now and like I'm doing
the same for her because she's going
through what she's going through and
yeah she's the most beautiful light
um
Everman and it's just you know I find
it's tougher for women to see who they
truly are too because the world is so
judgmental in terms of physical
appearance and and and
it it feels like such a big mountain to
climb from so it's just always about
letting her know how beautiful she truly
is inside and out because ultimately
um
no I just don't think our culture really
allows for that
and there's a better in your book around
when you you get married or you announce
you're together the amount of warnings
she gets from previous Partners how hard
is that for you to to know that's all
coming in and how has it for her to go
through all that as well yeah my wife is
a g bro like he handed it all like a g
yeah you read it as if to be like all of
these women
they're saying all these things like you
must have something going on that's mad
special like because you just saw it in
a completely different way yeah she
handled it like a gangster
um
didn't you babe
when when you were getting message from
like hundreds of women one dress
Millions
it was definitely seventy thousand it
wasn't seventy thousand people it was
more than hundreds let's put it that way
and they're the only ones who messaged
you yeah exactly yeah no she handed like
a G-Man to be fair like for me yeah
watching the way she handed it was just
was just fine for me man like
um
I didn't expect any for less remote
and talk to me about your plans going
forward like
um you're just sort of Sitting In Limbo
now you're about to do a um obviously
your book tour a lot of media coming up
um what about on the footy field
oh man you know what the way I feel
today like in my body right now I've
never felt this clear of mine like but
for the most elongated periods of the
day like I don't have those ups and
downs those moments I'm committed to a
frequency and energy state of joy and I
stay within it even if I say something
that might come across quite harsh if I
say something about Eddie or these
things I tweet it's from a loving place
but only from The Experience I'm never
critiquing the man I understand and have
compassion for his journey and being a
young mixed boy in Australia an awfully
racist country and
um
growing up small and always being second
choice and and you know having a bit
between your teeth that's going to
create some form of
velocity from you from your being you
know like I understand that difficulty
but
I also then don't accept certain
behaviors so like I say anyway I'm in a
complete state of Joy
um
and if I was to play now man I think it
would be the most amount of fun like I'm
playing football now every Monday and
Wednesdays and on Wednesdays it's a
really high level like some boys have
played in the Prem and been Pro and all
that I'm loving it just as much as I was
playing in front of 80 000 people like
to being locked in like using skills
using my understanding my awareness and
just pushing it to the test but
physically I've never felt clearer of
injuries and sharper I'm 35 and I feel
great um whether it comes or not
I'm so cool with it but if it does come
man it'd be great do you think you could
play professional football uh not now
I'm 35 like if I if I committed to it
when I was
well certain leagues I probably could
like if I play in Saudi um I probably
won't get the big contract I'll be on
pennies over there but I'd be part of
the squad
um
and I reckon like when I was 22 23 if I
committed I could have played a high
level yeah yeah and what about Cricket
how do you got Cricket these days I
haven't played for ages the last time I
played I was 18 I hadn't played for nine
months oh that's right and I went to
school with Jason Roy
in a place for England yeah yeah um
and they asked me to play because I was
involved in lots of training for rugby
and I played a game we played against
all these England Junior Bowlers I mean
Jay Roy we I got like 90 odd and he got
70 old or something like it was just so
much fun I got out to the worst late cut
ever like I remember it to the day I was
like I should have gotten 100 but anyway
yeah I haven't paid for a while I will
do this summer if an opportunity comes
for sure yeah and what about after after
you obviously finished either footy or
rugby
um obviously coaching must be a passion
of yours like hearing you talk reading
your story you obviously loved the game
I think you'd be a outstanding coach is
that something you'd like to go down uh
like like potentially
um
you know I I see I see a lot of
pre-seasons over here get wasted and
teams don't improve they just do a lot
of running and everyone gets great body
compositions and
um people get fit about the knowledge
the understanding the ability to attack
space take people on so on it doesn't
necessarily improve in preseason
pre-season is the biggest time that you
can do that in two weeks you can make a
massive change in a group like huge
changes if you do the correct
decision-making focused training so I
don't think like necessarily I want to
be a full-on coach like not right now I
definitely can tell I'd go in and I
would share and talk and get involved as
much as I could
um
I don't know how it's going to look but
I know I just want to make a big
difference man because I know I've I've
been in my mind and I've I've been
through the turmoil of a lot of things
and I live
I live in a very joyous State uh but
only through being accountable and
responsible for my actions yeah could
you see yourself coaching England
obviously you probably didn't have the
career you dreamed of as a player but as
a coach man how good some of the stuff
I've said about the rfu they know where
they've got the bottle
rugby in this country is like a giant
sixth form it's like people going oh no
I can't bring him into my team like come
on mate like let's just be real open
aligned it's a sport it's fun it's
joyous let's enjoy it yeah it's not the
be-all and end-all obviously it's
important it's people's livelihoods you
give everything you can in that moment
you do everything you possibly can
of course it's why we're here this is
life this is the life force of what
we're doing but you don't add on all
this extra pressure and and have to be
seen like just be real with it man yeah
and then the game over here would
flourish there's so many kids at this
game that would be amazing for I guess
unlikely England but maybe another
country well listen one day I'm not
writing anything off listen this I I
completely never ever in my life thought
I was going to meet the most amazing
woman fall in love and be in love with
one woman and never get my eye turn and
never be in that position of just being
completely like loved and Loved Someone
I didn't think I was worthy of it and I
do now
and I do I love her she loves me I'm
worthy of it all that stuff
to me that was the biggest
um
Miracle ever because I didn't see that
in my in my forecast in my future
um
so I know anything's possible bro yeah
nothing's impossible mate what what a
story and I guess the way we finish this
podcast most the times is uh put out
some questions to the Instagram Millions
came in for you probably a lot of your
ex
uh girlfriends Etc came in and a lot of
stories who wanted to know about okay
tell us a story about when you got hit
by a bus yeah so pre-season end of the
year 20 had a terrible season at sale
um
no other way to Galvanize the group than
to get pissed
um so we all went to lead on a mad end
of season
Jolly up or whatever it was and uh
yeah I was just messing about one of the
guys I was
about seven hours deeper drinking it was
only 8 p.m and I I've run across the
road thought the bus was stopping it
wasn't in
it collided with me but I'm here to tell
the story and the buses and so you know
it's part of it did it get rid off that
bass yeah absolutely
it did the pictures they're on the
internet mate don't worry about it
did it hurt
uh man not like I was so pissed I don't
and I got slightly concussed and it
might have given me a slight MCL
grade tear at one or two but you know I
live to tell the story it was way more
hurt than me I'll tell you that
what did the boys think that they think
he had
you were done or like that must have
been pretty scary on the Perth yeah the
boys I think everyone was pretty scared
because like people heard it from right
down the road just colliding with the
bus like
um and they know the boy there's a
picture of all the boys in fantasy dress
around me like in the pap in the picture
in the papers there's like Alice in
Wonderland the six foot five Alice in
Wonderland there's like six foot seven
uh tin can man or something like some
crazy [__] all just stood over me they
just was a comical moment but yeah I
almost died but yeah I'm just so
grateful that I'm here and I'm so happy
that I get to live life
oh that's good stuff well you obviously
smoke the bass but um another story
everyone wants to know about is the Josh
Lucy fight not sure if he smoked him as
much I didn't you know what but listen
again I got hit without knowing about it
what did you do uh Sean was wanting me
to like lead the group because at this
point at wasp it was a little bit of a
like
we weren't killing it like we normally I
was like wanted to get back into it's
like Daddy comes get into him
I'm 20 and I'm like normally I don't
lead in that fashion so I started
remembering how Alex king would speak to
people and he'd be like [__] you know so
I tried to do the same
and Josh is renowned for being the worst
trainer in the world like he will throw
four bad passes
and then blame everyone else and then
walk off the field he's done that before
anyway he's from the Army he's tough
Macho fella I'm only like 1920 and like
before I know he's hit me
but now I'm 35 I can't imagine hitting a
19 or 20 year old like
but yeah in England everyone passed off
as if I was the bad guy like yeah well
look getting two big boots cocky like
him in it mate I'm like as a 35 year old
man
for me to think about hitting a 20 year
old in in a game training because he's
maybe pushing buttons on my ego come on
man we need a bit of growing up to do
fellas yeah okay this is so interesting
at that age I was like yeah [__] it is
me like I generally and now I'm 35 I'm
like yeah I made this world so far yeah
like
do you know what um
if it was a fair fight Josh rematch
hell yeah
okay next one who's the best 10 in the
world right now in your opinion Richie
mulunga is it yeah okay yeah I think I
like the way he plays I see when he's
fully like in flow and not
I feel when he's in a back playing now
and it's great to see I think their line
out plays are slightly structured and I
know Joe Joe Smith's got a role in that
because he's probably tried to bring a
bit of solid solidarity around the plate
and around their face shape and
around the account it seems like New
Zealand are back to being what they are
um from line out I would say that they
need to start pushing the boundary a bit
because it's one of the best places to
attack like really but anyway
when I see Richie playing and he's like
especially for the Crusaders and also
for NZ yeah he's got a good flow to him
man um
for sure I would say for all tens like
spin past is important but when you go
to the line you've got the ball in a in
an end over end style fashion and you
can play short or go out the back or go
along with it yeah you hold the fenders
for a split second more yeah but a lot
of flowers go with the spin pass if
you've got a spin past at the line I
know you're going long or out the back
so I would just say manipulate the ball
a little bit I like the South African
guy libuk yeah I think he's got some
nice feel to him I love Willie Robert
10. even though he plays 15 I love him
stepping in um
uh he's a top player
um
yeah yeah nice options it's gonna be
some World Cup events can't wait to see
what happens yeah it is like with you
guys probably don't feel it there's a
lot of [__] going on in this country
regarding English rugby but I've heard a
little bit yeah he's under the pompe or
both way but in terms of the world game
it's going to be the best World Cup for
a while man yeah there's a lot of Team
Island New Zealand Africa France
England always on their day you don't
know what you're going to get man I know
right now it don't look great but even
Scotland hey are going pretty good
gotland can't write them off
um Finn Russell's a bit like uh Cipriani
similar he is he is he's a bit more
frivolous he's a bit more frivolous and
he's a bit more carefree and I do love
that element to him yeah I I had a
period of that when I was younger but I
then was working heavily on my decision
making like I could I was prided myself
on making good decisions but also being
able to make the impossible pass in the
moment too which he can do he just tries
a bit more of than me yeah
um
at the latter part of my career but yeah
thin muscle's got magic man he's a
serious player he can play okay couple
more is it true Lindsay Lohan got in a
fight over you yes
it was she just scrapping morning the
big dog back yeah it was yeah they were
just having a little tussle over old
d-sit that's what was going down then
what was that like for you the boys must
have given you a lot of [__] for that
sort of stuff man I was in America and
and uh
there was just loads of Paparazzi
everywhere it was just
it just didn't really seem like my life
but it was um
yeah it was funny to be fair yeah do you
look back at all these moments and think
far out like
this has been some crazy crazy life like
almost like it's not yours for real like
I'm 35 now I don't have
I don't dive into my memory loss I don't
really like
um
I don't utilize it that much because I
feel it
if I do then
I'm constantly gonna be living in things
that have gone on in the past and I
can't be present but if I sat down and
think about things or someone says
something that triggers something within
me then I
I remember that time and I'm like far
out it does seem like so long ago like
so much stuff has gone on um
but I'm so I'm so grateful for the whole
journey of it and you know I
I want the world to meet my wife because
ultimately
I can't be a bad guy if I've married
such an angel
oh I love it okay two more get him to
say the story of when he had too many
mushrooms
okay
damn
right in the book I'm gonna have to wait
you gotta leave something for the book
do you I've got to leave something for a
bit of you know a bit of mystery
um but yeah it was a heavy it was a
heavy experience man like I was thinking
and searching a lot of my life like from
24 I met an amazing Mentor into the
black and he taught me so much and
at that point I started training in
Malibu and training with a guy called
LED Hamilton who's a big wave surfer and
meeting lots of
you know really special people who had
different perspectives on lives and they
were introduced in lots of different
ways of healing lots of stuff that was
within me and one of the things
suggested that was going on was you know
Michael doson at a point later in my in
my life and um
I was always thinking and searching and
and
you know
at some point that falls away like in
this current state the way I feel now
it's not a necessity to go down that
route it's not a necessity to test like
take psychedelics it's not a necessity
to do all that
but where I was at and where I was
coming from the thing that was driving
me the pain the frustration that trying
to figure all these things out it's a
route I did go down and it did ease and
help some things for me but some people
don't have the most amazing stories
around it so I'm never advocating it or
ever telling people what to do
um but in the book you'll find out the
uh
the extent of that story yeah okay nice
nice little teaser one more um story
actually I forgot about this one this
was Willie Hines mentioned this one but
he wanted to know the true story of the
Jersey night out he doesn't often go out
with the boys so this must have been a
once in a lifetime experience for Herman
so what happened was we was in we was in
um a nightclub in Jersey yeah and
um
Willie was outside and he and I was
going to go get him in I had two drinks
I was gonna hand him one come in little
rum and coat let's go
um so I've gone out to
and the security is there like playing
the role of security I can't take
you and I was like okay cool and then
like they would try they kind of put
their hands on me a little bit and I
looked at him in the eyes and I downed
one and I down the other one I was like
can I go now and it was like cool so
I've gone outside to get him in
and then it's kind of just going there's
a bit of a fracus
no no pushing and shoving but for some
reason we can't get back in now
and they'd like
doing you know keeping us away and this
like little um
this uh the security guards are there
but then the the manager's there and
he's probably about I don't know five
eight five nine and he's giving it big
licks too so I just lean over and like
police Thai but it's a pull-up type yeah
it's a pull down Tire he didn't even do
a proper tie like I've taken the tie
I've just put it in my pocket and I've
walked off that is the extent of what
happened right within 60 seconds police
because Jersey's a tiny little white
little tiny little place yeah there's
only one nightclub there there's a
copper sitting waiting for people to get
up to trouble and
he
um
yeah I'm then getting cut they're trying
to arrest me
so this is the only bit that I probably
shouldn't have done
um was as these two guys are trying to
put my hand behind my back I'm there
going why am I getting arrested what
have I done yeah I'm asking him they
don't give me an answer so I pushed them
both off me and I'm like why am I
getting arrested and they won't give me
an answer but then I realize I'm like
okay I can't do that to the police
they're the law so
I was like okay arrest me but then they
put the cuffs on so tight
and put me down and I went my wrist
hurting I can feel pins and needles in
my hand can you loosen the cuff can you
loosen the cuff I'm telling him and he's
not doing it right yeah and then the Sun
newspaper the next day I've done a story
saying
that when I'm getting arrested and I'm
getting handcuffed I'm screaming these
wrists are golden loosen the cuff like
the [__] that they come up with man like
so then for the rest of that season
everyone's calling me golden wrists I
then go get players Player of the Year
being called Golden wrists so I'm kind
of like
jokes on you [__] I mean like
so stupid you said you set me up for it
you set me up for an outstanding season
oh that is so good
okay last question best piece of advice
you have for a woodland listener
um
best piece of advice would be to get a
sense of the game for yourself like
listen to your coaches but get a feel
for what you're doing for yourself
because you are the only person on the
field that can do it if you are always
following directives and orders you're
only ever going to be playing out
directives and orders you're always
going to be slightly off the beat
obviously there's parts of the game you
need to understand the team's framework
the coach's Vision uh his his views on
leadership how he conducts himself do it
with respect obviously
but in terms of learning yourself and
your movement in your body in the field
going Express and have fun with that
like don't get rigid and tight because
over here we see people like catching
forwards and running straight and they
look like
um
they look like little washing machines
running forward like they don't there's
no relaxation in their shoulders
um so I just yeah just get a bit of
movement and and flow in it and don't
hype everything up to the contact of the
game the contact's coming you're going
to be fine like you're going to be good
right what a way to finish you've got to
get into coaching I would be wasted to
not see you get into coaching at some
point I mean I I coached from 20
14. yeah 2013 to 2020 yeah while I was
playing and I loved it and every time I
went to
uh you know we outperformed well we
didn't outperform we the Improvement
despite the the place in the table
spiked the the efficiency of everyone's
gameplay spiked and that's got nothing
to do with me it was I'm not saying I
did that
if you give a perspective ruin rugby
over here which is slightly different
it's really easy for the boys to dive
into it and go and do it because it's
them that do it it's the players that go
and do it any coach that takes any
responsibility or praise for it is an
egotistical mofo like you can give a
directive or a verbal or information but
as soon as that player plays well you
had nothing to do with it yeah you just
sit back and enjoy it
like enjoy what he does
and then that will keep your ego out of
it and then that will also keep you
from
give an emotional directives and giving
clear and concise ones that's how I feel
right hundred percent in what a way to
finish the podcast mate I was super
excited to have you on and man that has
not disappointed like you go through
your story
um there's obviously moments throughout
it we are it's hard not to feel sorry
for what you've got had to go through
but then to see on the other side I'm so
happy don't don't feel sorry for me for
a second I feel so strong yeah
internally because of everything I've
faced hundred percent I'm unafraid to go
and speak and say what I got to say now
like even if the world right now thinks
I'm X Y and Z no one knows what I'm
liking these four walls by people that
do speak to me yeah and I know myself to
to the core now whereas I used to get
all my external validation outside from
playing or people's views or opinions of
me I was a kid growing up I didn't know
nobody now I do
I'm good all right 100 and your
brother's a legend too he speaks very
highly of you as well so does um Willie
Hines I love how
um your brother right used to get a
little bit tipsy and he would just he
would he would just help all these boys
what he thinks about them
he'd take them to the green room or
something would they call it oh make the
green room mate go to the [__] green
room with marching me I loved that
because it was like this guy's telling
people what the [__] is up and what is
what is a parent like in England they
don't do that we all dance with banter
and dance around the circles like he was
just like no you're a dick
because of X Y and Z and it was normally
right and people were like far out man
like he was some sort of Guru when he
got in the Green Room The Green Room is
a special place yeah Willie Heinz the
legend too man his family's awesome like
Tommy Marshall best flight
they're just great people man I really
enjoyed that um really enjoyed them when
I was a glossed up anyway it's been
awesome to have you on loved watching
you as a player um really appreciate
um you're giving up your time and coming
on and anyone listening make sure you go
get a cop copy of this book I I honestly
hand on heart say it is the best
autobiography I've read
um just blew me away I couldn't put it
down two days I'm not even a big read
and I've done it in two days thank you
Ben I appreciate you coming on you're a
true legend
give it my best